critiqué pour sa gestion de l'épidémie
donald trump a pris hier une mesure sans
précédent
le président américain a déclaré l'état
d'urgence une mesure traditionnellement
réservé aux catastrophes naturelles
un dispositif qui devrait permettre à
l'état fédéral de débloquer jusqu'à 50
milliards de dollars
le secteur privé vont aussi contribuer à
l'effort national
les laboratoires mobiles et le géant
google travaille déjà pour accélérer le
dépistage en vertu du plan pouvoir du
gouvernement fédéral je déclare
officiellement un état d'urgence
nationale deux très grands mots
la décision que je prends doit permettre
l'accès à 50 milliards de dollars
c'est un montant très élevé est très
important pour les états les territoires
et les localités afin qu'ils puissent
lutter contre cette maladie
chaque état doit mettre en place des
opérations d'urgence
et cette décision prend effet
immédiatement certaines des plus grandes
sociétés les plus grands commerces et
des plus grandes firmes médical du monde
vont s'adresser avant ces sociétés se
tiennent derrière est à côté de moi
la présidente démocrate de la chambre
des représentants nancy pelosi a annoncé
ce vendredi un accord avec
l'administration trump pour lutter
contre le coronavirus une série de
mesures pour venir en aide aux familles
avec au programme une baisse des
cotisations salariales une aide aux
congés maladie et le renforcement de
l'assurance chômage
une action rapide des démocrates pour
faire passer ce financement d'urgence
était essentielle à la réponse attendue
depuis longtemps de notre pays
le week-end dernier le leader démocrate
du sénat chômeurs et moi avons appelé à
de nouvelles mesures pour faire passer
les familles en premier aujourd'hui nous
adoptons un projet de loi qui fait c'est
exactement cela
le family first coronavirus response
actes qui visent directement à fournir
un soutien aux familles américaines qui
doivent être notre première priorité aux
etats-unis le problème est donc pris à
bras le corps
elles selon le président américain s'en
sont mille tests de dépistages vont être
disponible dès la semaine prochaine
cinq millions d'ici un mois en ces temps
d'affrontements politiques démocrates et
républicains malgré la campagne
présidentielle ont donc décidé de se
battre ensemble pour endiguer l'épidémie
qui a déjà contaminé plus de 2000
personnes et fait au moins 47 morts sur
le territoire américain
[Musique]